so in the midst of everything else
things have also been heating up in the
world by which i don't mean global
warming although President Obama's you
allow ratification of the climate
control treaty by executive order
perhaps has something to do with the
topic this afternoon we're all watching
the Middle East in the rising threat of
terrorism to be sure but some very
interesting things have been happening
in Europe going back several years now
you will recall the eurozone debacle and
the chaos in Greece Europe's migrant
crisis continues to spin out of control
established political parties on the
decline across the continent while
protests parties rise and then of course
there is brexit in June the United
Kingdom voted by reference to leave the
European Union who would have thunk the
European project seems to be perhaps
unraveling Todd Huizinga is a senior
fellow at the Paul be Henry Institute
for study of Christianity and politics
at Calvin College in Grand Rapids
Michigan he received to be a music in
German from Calvin College and ma and
German language and literature from the
University of wisconsin-madison he's the
director of international outreach for
the Acton Institute and it serves the US
diplomat in Luxembourg Belgium Germany
Mexico Ireland and Costa Rica in
addition to the European affairs bureau
of the united states department of state
in 2013 he co-founded the transatlantic
christian council a nonprofit
corporation that promotes limited
government the free market individual
liberty and civic virtue on both sides
of the Atlantic he is the author of the
new totalitarian temptation global
governance and the crisis of democracy
in Europe and he speak to us this
afternoon on sovereignty and politics
time
thank you Matt president iron ladies and
gentlemen it's a great honor for me to
be here especially I have to say as a
Michigan der nacht Michigan Ian most
michiganders SE michigan turn at
michigan Ian as a Michigan der born and
raised in Grand Rapids Michigan and now
living again in the grand rapids area
after 20 years as a diplomat in the
Foreign Service I'm delighted in honor
to be here in washington DC at an event
of Hillsdale College not only one of the
finest colleges in Michigan I would have
said the finest college in michigan but
I'm affiliated with Calvin College which
is in Michigan's I can't say that not
only one of the finest colleges in
Michigan but truly one of the finest
colleges in the entire United States I
can tell you I can tell you that my wife
and I you know are already kind of
planning out where our daughter who is
15 our youngest daughter will go to
college you know planning her life for
her and all that as parents do and we're
already doing our best to nudge her
toward applying for Hillsdale and I was
going to say toward going to Hillsdale
but then president iron was talking
about how difficult it is to get into
Hillsdale so that struck a little fear
in my heart so now I'll say to apply to
Hillsdale which I hope she'll be
accepted
thank you yes
fantastic mrs. excellent ladies and
gentlemen sovereignty especially
American sovereignty stands in the way
of a better world that we could all have
it keeps us from building the
institutions that we need to achieve
full respect for human rights globally
self-government is a myth what so-called
self-government really does is
perpetuate the oppression of the
marginalized and the week the American
obsession with America is a major
obstacle to transforming the world these
are the inescapable conclusions of the
world view of most of our compatriots on
the American left and the majority of
our allies in Europe thus it is
fortunate that many people never reach
the inescapable conclusions of their
foundational beliefs nevertheless we
cannot ignore the volatile instability
of living in a world in which political
differences among compatriots and allies
are no longer based on different
perspectives within a shared worldview
but rather on diametrically opposed
presuppositions about first things about
what is good what is true and what it
means to be human in this talk I will
try to get to the roots of the conflict
between the idea of democratic
sovereignty and its principle though
inch of insufficiently noticed
ideological rival of the last 20 or 25
years the global governance ideology I
will outline how supra nationalism
governance above the nation state level
how that functions in the European Union
which is the only existing model of how
a regime of global governance might
actually work I will discuss the
European Union's vision for the world at
large a world organized and pacified the
structures of global governance then I
will do my best to describe
how this EU vision clashes with the
American vision of democratic
sovereignty and present one major aspect
of the deeper worldview roots of this
transatlantic disconnection and finally
I'll try to explain why and how a
trickle-down post-modernism a deeply
relativistic denial of objective truth
is translating into an intrusive
globalist vision of a new human rights
achieved and enforced by global
governance throughout my plea is for
democratic sovereignty anchored in a
humble respect for truth and a
recognition of the limits of politics as
the only basis for realizing
self-government and justice and freedom
first a clarification by sovereignty I
just want to say this I mean the
understanding of national sovereignty on
which the American experiment is based
the idea that self-government is rooted
in the nation-state and accordingly that
the Constitution as our basic law trumps
any international law that might
contravene it in the arena of
International Affairs national
sovereignty does not mean any sort of
splendid isolation nor does it mean the
renunciation of international
cooperation rather it simply means that
the United States insists on its right
to participate in international affairs
as a sovereign nation state it means
that the US government is responsible
primarily to its own citizens and that
its powers are circumscribed not by the
desires of other nations but only by its
constitution which the American people
accept as the basic law against which
the legitimacy of all other laws
treaties and agreements must be judged
and here is we've heard many times
during this conference the concept of We
the People is key in the u.s. system
sovereignty resides in his citizens
endowed by their creator with certain
unalienable rights sovereignty does not
reside in the government
the power and authority of the US
government are derived from the American
people and the American people alone
this is what Hudson Institute's scholar
John Fante who happens to be in the
audience today calls philadelphian
sovereignty or democratic sovereignty
democratic sovereignty is the
sovereignty of a self-governing free
people democratic sovereignty is the
heart of the model of government
elaborated by the framers of the US
Constitution and America's most precious
gift to the world but there is a problem
with this precious gift to the world
democratic sovereignty entails limited
government and thus limited ambitions
for government as it happens democratic
sovereignty is also rooted in a
traditionalist and essentially religious
essentially judeo-christian worldview
for the most part neither the American
left nor our European partners advocate
this type of limited government and they
certainly do not hold anything
resembling a traditionalist worldview in
general in fact most of our closest
allies in Western Europe and they are
our closest allies in Western Europe I
want to emphasize that most of our
closest allies in Europe belong to an
organization whose very reason for being
is the rejection of sovereigntist limits
on government namely the European Union
to be sure with the eurozone crisis as
Matt mentioned the refugee crisis
widespread terrorism and now brexit the
European Union is in deep trouble
because of these crises the words
European Union are in everyone's lips
but despite all of the attention it is
attracted recently very few people
really know much about the EU in fact
very few people have the foggiest idea
what the European Union is and that is
understandable why is it understandable
because the EU is unlike any other
international arrangement although
economic integration was the European
projects star
point the EU is much more than say a
free-trade area like NAFTA neither is it
like any other international
organization that might at first seem
comparable take the Organization of
American States the OAS the u.s. belongs
to the Organization of American States
both the EU and the OAS are regional
organizations and just as the OAS is
virtually pan-american so the EU is
close to being pan-european but the
similarities between the OAS and the EU
and they're the 28 EU member states
hopefully soon to be the 27 EU member
states after britain actually leaves the
28 EU member states were their constant
policy coordination and they're powerful
common institutions and brussels are
much more closely integrated than the
member states of the OAS or those of any
other international organization yet on
the other hand the EU is nothing like a
United States of Europe it's more than
an international organization but it's
less than a nation-state and the EU
member states continue to exist as
independent nations the EU is is a
fascinating both and or neither nor
organization so what is the EU well you
know there would be many answers to that
question my answer to that question is
that when all is said and done what it
comes down to is that the EU is a Supra
nationalist project the EU member states
in the interest of realizing an
unprecedented degree of peace stability
and prosperity are pooling and thus
relinquishing significant elements of
their national sovereignty they are
ceding large aspects of their governing
governing and lawmaking powers to the
supranational EU institutions that are
distinct from the EU member states and
that function independently above the
national level the essence of the
European project the e u--'s hope the e
u--'s heart and soul is precisely this
supra nationalism
the process of European integration
arose out of the ashes of World War two
and the determination of europeans and
their leaders that war should never
arise again from European sole soil that
violent conflicts among European nation
states should never happen again this
was a noble vision it was an
understandable vision given the
devastation wrought by World War two and
before that by world war one and despite
all of its problems it remains a
powerful vision today despite brexit it
remains a powerful vision today the
vision of a harmonious and peaceful
europe united in the european union with
fins and Cypriots and irish and dutch
and everyone else all working together
for a better world but the european
union is not just about europe the EU
supra nationalism is all about global
governance putting the e use form of
supranational governance into practice
on a global scale in order to realize
world peace by overcoming the inordinate
sovereignty of Nations which the EU
believes to be the primary root of war
among nations and here the EU with all
its troubles does have credibility after
all it is the only functioning model of
how such global governance might
actually work so what is global
governance here's how I would define it
leaning again on John fontes seminal
work on this topic global governance is
the attempt to introduce a global rule
of law in the interest of achieving an
unprecedented degree of worldwide peace
stability and prosperity not via a
one-world government but rather by the
development of a ever more comprehensive
network of international organizations
that administer an ever greater body of
international law to which nation states
are subject and which binds them not
only in their foreign policy but also in
substantial areas of their domestic
policy the key to global governance is
the development of a global
rule of law whereby no one knows exactly
what this global rule of law will look
like in the end and no one actually even
knows I don't think if an end is ever
meant to be achieved the EU is also kind
of an internal process so whatever this
end state might be that the EU advocates
of a global rule of law have in mind
there's obviously a clash of visions
between the e u--'s notion of an entire
world organized by the structures of
global governance and the American idea
of democratic sovereignty of
self-government based in the nation
state even though the Western and
Central European countries remain among
our closest allies this puts the EU and
the US on a collision course in
principle if not always thank God in
practice and it cannot be otherwise as
the world's most powerful nation state
and one that traditionally jealously
guards its national sovereignty the
United States by its very existence
stands in the way of the EU vision of a
world that has evolved beyond the
nation-state what is that the root of
all this well there are many factors
that have led to this difference between
the u.s. and the EU and not just the
post-war desire to that i mentioned to
do away with conflicts among european
nations a central factor that has led to
this difference I believe is the
religious difference between the u.s.
and the EU despite what's been happening
recently the u.s. is the most
judeo-christian of the modern developed
societies of the world the EU by
contrast is largely secular the u.s.
system of government is based on a very
sober very judeo-christian view of human
nature and thus of government this is
the whole reason for the separation of
powers and the checks and balances
foreseen in the US Constitution it is
striking for example how deeply indebted
the federalist papers are to
Christianity regardless of whether the
authors and
were believing Christians or not
Hamilton Madison and Jay accepted that
human beings while capable of great good
were also flawed sinful as Christians
would put it there for the powers of
government had to be limited and divided
into multiple branches so that the
flawed human beings who hold
governmental power could not impose a
tyranny on everyone else and I would
argue that these views on human nature
that inform the Federalist Papers and
the US Constitution are still the
prevailing instinctive views of most
Americans today regardless of whether
most Americans today are believing
Christians or Jews or not culturally
America especially compared to Europe is
more judeo-christian than not the EU
super nationalism on the other hand
flows out of a basically secular social
democratic view of human nature out of
the idea that social justice can be
achieved through government action and
government planning and this is not just
a can can be achieved is also a must
must be achieved for most people in post
Christian Europe and certainly for the
governing elites this world is all there
is thus justice must be determined by
human beings and pursued via politics
and government but of course things are
fluid the us-eu clash of visions might
be moving toward resolution and not in
favor of democratic sovereignty if one
judges by the crises buffeting the
European Union global governance may
appear to be on the wane but brexit or
no brexit the animating world view of
global governance is not on the wane it
is gaining ground in the United States
as well in fact the world view behind
global governance may be close to
winning the day throughout the West the
specter of an inchoate trickle down form
of post-modernism is haunting the West
it has become for many of us the
implicit basis upon which we think a
standard definition describes
post-modernism as I quote characterized
by broad skepticism subjectivism or
relativism a general suspicion of reason
and an acute sensitivity to the role of
ideology in a searching and maintaining
political and economic power close quote
this type of suggests subjective istic
relativism this suspicion that truth is
not really truth but simply the tool the
politically and economically powerful
has seeped into virtually all areas of
life this inchoate post-modernism
rejects the idea that there is any truth
claim that can command greater
allegiance than the feelings or opinions
of any individual or group especially if
the individual or group is deemed to be
oppressed or disadvantaged reality
itself is nothing more than what each
individual or group feels it to be
individual choice and group identity
rain and reality can and must be
reshaped in the service of individual
choice and group identity ultimately the
only thing that is objectively true is
my subjective assessment of what is true
for me and in the sphere of
international politics very interesting
development in the sphere of
international politics the spirit of
post-modernism has seized the
opportunity presented by the end of the
Cold War for new ways of thinking about
world order in the last 25 years
political post-modernism has shunned the
old certainties of modernism the belief
in reason in the no ability of truth for
example in order to create space for a
new view of politics political
post-modernism has gone a long way
toward bringing about a trance valuation
of all political values a deconstruction
and redefinition of
the categories associated with modernity
such as for example the nation state
national sovereignty international law
and human rights in order to assert a
new post national view of governance in
a new kind of human rights based on a
denial of truth and on a commitment to
the absolute autonomy of the individual
and the absolute priority of free choice
no longer does human rights mean the
right to live speak and act in
accordance with the unchanging truth
about human nature in accordance with
that which promotes human flourishing
rather human rights now stands for the
right of the atomized individual to
transform himself or herself in whatever
way he or she chooses and to be
liberated from the constraints imposed
by the truth claims of others global
governance and the new human rights
serve as the twin pillars of this post
Cold War political post-modernism they
are interdependent without global
governance there can be no global
realization of the new human rights and
without the new human rights global
governance loses much of its purpose the
Belgian American social critic
Marguerite Peters has characterized this
intertwining of global governance and
the new human rights as the new global
ethic this global ethic like the EU and
global governance movement is again a
child of post modernity the basic tenets
of which is and I quote that every
reality is a social construct that truth
and reality have no stable and objective
content that in fact they do not exist
close quote as painters put it puts it
human rights as understood in the global
ethic promotes the liberation of man and
woman from the conditions of existence
in which God has placed them personal
autonomy Trump's all outside constraints
and truth claims since the individual in
order to exercise his right to
shoes must be able to free himself from
all normative frameworks in fact the
right to choose as Peters observed has
become the fundamental norm governing
the interpretation of all human rights
human rights are now defined as the
right to choose but aren't human rights
good for that matter isn't freedom of
choice good who could possibly be
against human rights and freedom of
choice yes human rights rightly
understood and freedom of choice rightly
understood are inherent and inalienable
but what you believe about human rights
depends on what you believe about human
beings and here we've seen that the
worldview change to postmodernism that
I've just outlined namely the turning
away from a judeo-christian a basically
judeo-christian culture to one rooted in
relativism has profoundly affected the
idea of human rights based on the notion
of the absolute autonomy of the
individual the notion of choice taken to
its ultimate extent the new human rights
are transformative and liberationists
unsurprisingly the new human rights
center exactly on those human rights
that Western secularists seem to care
most about women's rights defined as the
right to choose children's rights under
the framework of the autonomous child
who should have freedom of decision and
LGBT rights the ideas of transformation
and liberation are central here just as
the global governance movement seeks to
transform the world in the globalists
image liberating peoples from their
traditional allegiances to local
communities and nation-states the
postmodern view of Human Rights promotes
a redefinition of people as autonomous
individuals who can choose to transform
their very nature and in so choosing not
only transform themselves but also
liberate themselves from the constraints
of traditional social bonds
in the case of women's and children's
rights liberation from the constraints
of the family is a core concern in the
case of LGBT rights the transformative
aspect is central the concept of the
flexible self-defined gender identity
overrides even the empirical reality
that every human being is either a man
or a woman but ironically such radical
transformation and liberation such total
freedom of choice cannot be brought
about without the significant exercise
of government power or at the very least
government suasion in suppressing the
truth now again all human beings women
children LGBT people everyone shares
inherent and inalienable but the notion
of the universality of Human Rights
serves a fascinating function in
promoting the human rights of unlimited
freedom of choice let me quote from a
statement of EU foreign ministers from
2013 entitled guidelines to promote and
protect the enjoyment of all human
rights by lesbian gay bisexual transect
transgender and intersex persons this
statement states that I quote the EU is
committed to the principle of the
universality of Human Rights and
reaffirms that cultural traditional or
religious values cannot be invoked to
justify any form of discrimination
including discrimination against LGBT I
persons the statement was approved by
all of the EU foreign ministers
including you know basically Catholic
countries like Poland approved by all
the you foreign ministers and it
declares LGBTI rights to be absolute and
valid in all contexts while relative
izing cultural traditional or religious
values it is truly ironic how religion
which in the West is the primary source
of the idea of object
truth is declared by relativists to be
of only relative subjective validity
while LGBTI rights are given the status
of objective universal truth by the
unwitting proponents of a worldview that
denies that there is objective universal
truth so clearly the new human rights
are a non-negotiable priority of the
global governance agenda but a gaping
hole of uncertainty has opened up
because the new human rights are based
implicitly on a rejection of anything
that is traditionally client claimed the
mantle of objective truth since
objective truth has been rejected
everything traditional everything
religious everything true is now up for
grabs including the question of what
human rights are this uncertainty this
question of what human rights are
demands resolution thus it becomes
inevitable that human rights themselves
will be rida terminals who are
supposedly being liberated to transform
themselves as they choose but rather by
none other than those who hold political
power in a world without the authority
of objective truth only those who hold
political power have authority that can
be okay that can be enforced in
principle no relativist is far from
mouths a tongues famous dictum that
political power grows out of the barrel
of a gun thus the so-called unlimited
right to choose of the individual
becomes the unlimited right of the
government to decide what may or may not
be chosen so government as guarantor of
universal human rights expands is this
but as if by sleight of hand to
government as master and with a global
reach of communications travel commerce
and ideas government as master expands
geographically also
just as government power to determine
what human rights are are is in
principle unlimited so also it becomes
impossible to limit the power of
government to a certain geographical
area or people global governance becomes
the only rational option and national
sovereignty becomes I'm speaking again
in principle here in principle national
sovereignty becomes an impermissible
limit on the elites power to decide for
everyone what is just and true and so
the postmodern political project thus
unmasks itself not as a benign desire to
improve humanity's lot but instead as an
unlimited power grab to define truth and
justice under the banner of universal
human rights what the european union
says about the post-2015 development
agenda and its sustainable development
goals probably the UN's most
highly-touted global governance project
currently what the EU says about this
project illustrates the intrusiveness
and the overwhelming scale the
postmodern political project of global
governance let me quote from a statement
of EU of the EU council of ministers
that is particularly revealing of how
the EU in its heart of hearts aims to
achieve a utopian level of Human Rights
via ill-defined yet all encompassing
structures of global governance I quote
the post-2015 agenda should therefore
integrate the three dimensions of
sustainable development in a balanced
way across the agenda ensure coherence
and synergies and address inter-linkages
throughout the goals and targets it is
also crucial to ensure that the agenda
encompasses all human rights and that it
respects supports and builds on existing
multilateral agreements conventions
commitments commitments and processes
the agenda should leave no one behind in
particular it must address without any
discrimination
the elderly and person I'm sorry I
missed it must address without
discrimination the needs of the most
disadvantaged and vulnerable including
children the elderly and persons with
disabilities as well as of marginalized
groups and indigenous peoples and it
must respond to the aspirations of young
people we should ensure that no person
wherever they live and regardless of an
ethnicity gender age disability religion
or belief race or other status is denied
universal human rights end quote I
wonder I went to uh I want to your
stress that this is by the EU council of
ministers which is the EU institution
where the member states are represented
thus it was a statement of people who
belong to elected governments that
institution the you not the European
Commission not to separate its
bureaucrats the people who belong to
elected governments but acting super
nationally so as you can see here
governance politics is universal global
all-encompassing and comprehensive there
are no constraints no limits neither
geographical nor its aspiration ille
there are no checks and balances to
stand in the way of the good that can be
accomplished by the global elite the
language here is almost messianic
ascribing a quasi salvific power to
politics and governance it sets aside
the West's traditionally judeo-christian
recognition of human fallibility for the
notion that via activist global
governance the world can be transformed
and human beings liberated from the
constraints of tradition culture and
religion and the United States is far
from immune from this our system of
self-government is eroding from both
ends on the one end our freedom
internally is being undermined by a
crippling regime of political
correctness at its core I believe that
political correctness is post-modernism
as manifested in identity politics the
elites of each
group in defining that group's identity
become the arbiters of that groups own
version of the truth of its truth about
itself for each group there is no
objective truth distinct from that
group's identity and the justice that
each group demands is that society at
large not only recognize but also
support in language thought and
legislation that groups self-definition
of its tribal truth we see this now
especially in the LGBT rights and gender
identity movement and in the resulting
challenges coming from all corners to
the religious liberty of traditional
Christians we see it by the way also in
the black lives matter movement where it
becomes unacceptable to challenge black
lives matters groups ideas about the
status of African Americans in the
United States and what's happening in
the United States so while our freedom
of language thought and legislation is
being undermined on the one end by
political correctness on the other end
our national sovereignty is under
assault by a fashionable globalism which
is a particularly American version of
the global governance ideology Supreme
Court justices site foreign Court
rulings as support for their judgment on
American constitutional questions
left-wing NGOs push unofficial
tendentious interpretations of UN human
rights agreements to assert rights
heretofore non-existent in US law and
jurisprudence and implicitly to deny
Americans constitutional rights if these
constitutional rights conflict with the
new human rights in my view that our
situation is the following whether we
want to be or not we who believe in
self-government are engaged in a battle
that goes much deeper than mere
political differences in the US and our
domestic politics and in our
relationship with our Europe
in allies we can no longer rely on a
basic Western world view consensus we
can no longer safely appeal to truth
objective truth or to normative claims
about human nature the judeo-christian
view of an unchanging human nature
embedded in tradition religion community
and family the worldview that grounds
self-government in the West no longer
commands the general allegiance of our
Western societies and the partisans of
the post modern political project of
global governance and the new human
rights are committed to a radically
secularist view of this of the virtually
unlimited malleability change ability of
human nature according to each person's
choice essentially independent of
traditional institutions and social
relations as I said earlier there are no
limits no borders in the rhetoric and
preferred practice of political
post-modernism there are neither
national borders nor limits to the
powers governments should wield in the
non-negotiable pursuit of universal
human rights the contest between
democratic sovereignty self-government
and global governance is a zero-sum game
as John is written the two are implicit
Leah posed and democratic sovereignty
anchored in a humble respect for truth
and a recognition of the limits of
politics remains the only basis for
realizing self-government in justice and
freedom well we want to or not this
battle of worldviews is a fight that we
cannot avoid is a fight for self-evident
truths for objective truth and reason as
basis for tolerance communication and
persuasion across differences and for
the idea that government derives its
powers from the consent of the governed
and not from the elites who know better
we are in this battle so let's engage in
it and let's do so in a way that seeks
the good not only for ourselves but also
for our opponents thank you very much
we have time for some questions and we
have microphones here if you would raise
your hand I thank you so much a Tyler
O'Neill with pj media my question is how
would you differentiate so you linked
the postmodern view of society to this
global governance idea but some might
counter that the basic idea of natural
law and the way that even the American
Constitution was developed historically
came from international laws and
governance that were developed in the
Scholastic period in you know the among
the Spanish scholastics and forward into
our own day so there could be an
argument that to a certain extent global
governance has been a project of the
West and that we're trying to bring
about the objective truths of natural
law in the interaction between nations
how does that differ from global
governance as you see it in in this
movement and why is that so important to
note that difference thank you thank you
yeah as I said in the international
arena the fact that America engages as a
sovereign nation state in world politics
does not mean that were isolated from
the rest of the world nor does it mean
that we have any aversion at all to
international agreements it simply means
that we participate in international
affairs as a sovereign nation state that
governs itself and so the United States
has nothing against international law
that it is recognized as legitimate by
signing and ratifying treaties and other
agreements so long as there are no
stipulations in that agreement or treaty
that violate the US Constitution
the US Constitution has to remain our
basic law because we have as Americans
have decided that that's a basic law now
there have been you know there's always
I think utopian elements let's say in
thinking about politics and governance
you know and this I think is the reason
for the very interesting and very very
sensitive very difficult connection that
there is there is between religious
faith and politics you know I for
example do not believe in a Christian
America you know obviously I'm a
Christian but I don't believe in a
Christian America nonetheless I think I
think it has to be obvious to everyone
that because politics is about ordering
the world in order to achieve the
greatest good for Humanity politics is
all about similar questions to religion
namely what is good what is humanity etc
so there's always been kind of utopian
impulses okay but the idea of kind of an
overarching one world governing
structure that would be very very
different let me emphasize again from a
one-world government that's not what I'm
talking about the idea of kind of
organizing the world be an ever-growing
web of international institutions
administrating never growing body of
international law that is a utopian idea
that goes far beyond you know the
traditional thinking about international
law and international relations in the
judeo-christian West it's utopian and it
it it it totally flies in the face of
the judeo-christian recognition that
human beings are limited and flawed and
that politics is not the way to
salvation that politics is not the way
to heaven on earth now global governance
and human rights I think you're
absolutely right that there is not a
there's not a necessary connection
between global governance and the new
human rights I do believe however that
it makes a lot of sense that this
connection hasn't
has in fact developed because of the
similarities between the post modernity
of global governance and the post
modernity of Human Rights global
governance flies in the face of obvious
truths about human nature in the world
in attempting to kind of liberate people
from where they come from from their
language their cultures their traditions
and to organize them in some unified way
in a global level in the same way from
kind of the opposite end the global
governance and is a very interesting
kind of collective post modernity
whereas the new human rights are usually
a kind of individualistic post maternity
wear you know each individual's choice
freedom of choice liberate them to
transform themselves from a man to a
woman or from a mother to a non mother
or from a child to an adult who suddenly
at 10 years old can decide for himself
and doesn't need his parents to tell him
what to do or what to think so so I
guess here that the the connection is
the postmodern denial of obvious truths
about human beings in the world the
connection is also that it's basically
arisen in politics both of these things
since the end of the Cold War the cold
you're the end of the Cold War really
opened up space for the postmodern
thinking to come in and think about new
ways to order the world so it's also
similar from that and I would say that
the two main things that connect it are
the ideas of transformation and
liberation the idea that governance
structures can transform the world and
liberate people's from their communities
their traditions their religions that
might be oppressive and the idea that
the new human rights can liberate
individuals from the communities and the
truths and the traditions that tell them
that human nature is a certain way and
you don't have unlimited freedom of
choice Todd this is really amazing thank
you for teasing out what you're seeing
and what you've understood this is
really amazing so many of us are
thinking about 53 days from now and the
choice that Americans will make between
Trump and Clinton how is what you're
seeing in this big battle evident in the
two choices that Americans are going to
have yeah that's a very very good
question you know I guess like everybody
else or at least like everybody else
says I see a lot of problems with Donald
Trump Donald Trump is a very unusual
person I happen to like as a as a really
polite Midwestern ER I haven't like
Donald Trump's very impolite New York
humor actually I think that's great but
he's a very problematic person but to me
it just seems that i'm standing on what
Jonah Goldberg says was was the only
thing that he can support in terms of a
Donald Trump supporter it's like Hillary
I'm all-in against Hillary Clinton and
therefore I'm going to vote for Donald
Trump because voting for Gary Johnson
you know is there's no reason to do it
and and yes yes and so that was my maybe
I got a little too political there which
is a diplomate I'm not used to doing I
have to tell you I used to be in
meetings with people from other
countries than they would be telling me
their political opinions and I would be
kind of withholding nine and I'd be
shaking my head on the way to the subway
or whatever thinking oh man I'm so tired
of listening to this and not saying
anything anyway so now I got to have my
say you know
Hillary Clinton is a representative of
the American left and you know I believe
that most people should take politicians
at their word that multiple editions
even ones who care about the polls more
than others usually say what they mean
and that there's no reason to believe
they're not they don't mean what they
say unless you have a specific reason to
not to believe that and so I don't think
that Hillary Clinton for example moved
to the left just because she's adjusting
to the left wing changes in the
Democratic Party I believe that she my
impression is that she truly believes
you know that LGBT rights Trump
religious freedom but as she said
religious convictions about abortion
that many Americans have are just going
to have to be changed I mean it's
amazing that a presidential candidate
said that without shame that she
believes all these things she believes
in the transformative power of politics
and she believes that truth can be
twisted in order to achieve what people
want especially if they're marginalized
or oppressed thus she is a member of a
democratic party that really believes in
this incipient post-modernism in let me
let me just say that I'm not saying that
Hillary Clinton would say i am a
postmodernist I said trickle-down
post-modernism inchoate post-modernism
it's unreflective but if you try to get
to the roots of what people are thinking
I think it is a trip a trickle-down
post-modernism and Hillary Clinton fully
represents that Donald Trump does not
love one last question briefly this was
predicted in I think by in principle by
CS lewis in the abolition of man and
what you've talked about it seems to be
the actual practical fulfillment of it
it called it the Masters and that the
abolition of man turns out to be man's
conquest of man a rebellion of the
branches against the trees how do you
see that and I'm sure you're familiar
with
book right I didn't quite there's
something wrong with the sound there i
didn't but CS lewis predicted this in
abolition of man yes in the early 40s i
thought yeah he called it a rebellion of
the branches against the trees because
the principles that we apply to to
commend our allegiance our behavior to
an objective standard is the only way
that you can justify changing a whole
set of morals or first principles yeah
so called a rebellion of the branches
against the trees just interested in
your comments and if you do feel this is
the fulfillment of the principles that
he had predicted the way the world was
heading what you've talked about today
seems that we're there yes well yes I
think that I think that CS lewis was
incredibly prophetic in the abolition of
man and i think we've come a long way
down that road and yes that is basically
what I'm saying however I also want to
say that I really don't believe that we
should engage too much in pessimism
strangely enough I believe that we
should fight for the truth that we
should fight that we should dare to say
the obvious that we should have
arguments to support what we say about
the obvious and I really do believe what
I said at the end that when we engage in
this battle of worldviews that we have
to do so for the good of our opponents
as well and that i do believe deeply
that there is no reason for any of us to
think we are any better than LGBT people
or intersex people or Democrats or
anything like that you know I believe in
sharp and pointed political debate but I
believe that the only way that we're
going to make progress to saving
democratic sovereignty and say
real human rights and reasserting them
is if we do so in a way that is
consistently charitable toward everyone
including those who oppose us